i have some example problems here from
our equivalent vectors exercise on khan
academy so let's let's go through these
and and like always pause the video and
see if you could work through them on
your own
so this first one it says are vectors u
and vector w equivalent and so we can
see vector u here in blue and vector w
right over here and we have to remember
a vector is defined by both having a
magnitude and a direction and so for two
vectors to be equivalent they have to
have the same magnitude and the same
direction
so when i look at these two they are
clearly pointing in different directions
vector u is pointing to the bottom right
that's the direction it's pointing in
and vector w is pointing to the bottom
left so they definitely aren't they
definitely are not equivalent so let me
so they are not equivalent scratch that
out so they have different
different directions
different
directions
and let's think about the magnitude if i
just look at the length of the arrows
just eyeballing it they look pretty
close
let me let me verify that so if i'm
starting at the initial point for vector
u how much do i move in the x direction
on the x direction i go from let's see i
go from negative 8
to
negative 3. so i could say my change so
my change in x
is
positive 5. my x increases by 5 as i go
from the initial point from the x
coordinate of the initial point to the x
coordinate of the terminal point so that
length the magnitude of just the x-coor
the x-component is 5. and let's see what
happens in the y-direction
so in the y-direction i start at y
equals negative 2 right over here
and then
i go down to
y equals negative eight
so my change in y
change in y
is equal to
is equal to negative 6
negative 6.
now let's think about this one over here
what's my change in x
what's my change in x well i'm starting
at x equals 8
and i am going to x equals three
so my change in x is
negative five let me write that change
in x
is equal to
this is my change in x change in x and
then what's my change in y
well i start at y is equal to 8 and i go
down to y is equal to 2.
so
just like that
so my change in y is equal to negative
6.
now based on the changes in x's and y's
i can figure out the magnitude of each
of these vectors
the magnitude of
u so i could write it like this the
magnitude of u sometimes you'll see the
notation like this
the magnitude
of u of vector u i should say
is going to be equal to we're going to
use the pythagorean theorem here it's
going to be the square root the length
of this hour is just the hypotenuse of
the right triangle so it's going to be
the square root of 5 squared
plus negative 6 squared so it's going to
be the square root of 25
plus 36 which is equal to the square
root of what is that it's going to be 60
square root of 61. i can make that
radical a little bit smaller square root
of 61.
now what about what about vector w
so the magnitude
of vector w
is i'll i could use a double those
double bars the magnitude of vector w
well that's going to be the square root
of negative 5 squared which is 25 plus
negative 6 squared which is going to be
36 well that's going to be the square
root of 61 as well so they have the same
magnitude just different directions so
let's see no they have the same
magnitude but different directions yep
that's the choice we like let's do one
more of these
are vectors u and w equivalent all right
so these look pretty equivalent just
eyeballing it looks like they're pointed
in the same direction they're going from
the bottom left to the top right it
looks like they're the same length but
we can verify them once again verify
that once again by looking at their x
and y components
so in the x direction or thinking about
how much we change in x and change in y
when we go from the initial point to the
terminal point
so in the x direction
for vector u we go from negative 7
to
negative 4. so we increased by three
and what do we do over here we go from x
equals two to x equals five
so our x component once again has a
magnitude of three we are our change in
x is a positive 3.
and so our change in y what is that
going to be well we're going on this
vector from y equals whoops i'm using
the wrong
we're going from y is equal to 1 to y is
equal to 6
so the magnitude of the y component we
can say is 5 our change in y is a
positive 5
and then the change in y over here also
is a positive 5. we go from negative 7
to negative two it's also a positive
five
so notice our change in x is the same
it's a positive three our change in y is
the same positive five so that lets us
know that we have the same magnitude and
direction and so these are equivalent
these are
equivalent vectors and in fact as we see
as we'll see in the future you can
actually denote a vector by its
components we could say that vector u
vector u
is the vector
five comma oh sorry the vector three
comma five our change in x
comma our change
our change in y and that is exactly the
same as vector w
so that is exactly the same as vector w
has the same change in x same changes y
as we go from the initial point to the
tip of the arrow the terminal point